Welcome to the assignments for lesson four. First, congratulations on
making it this far in the course. Hopefully you're really starting
to see your identity as a designer change and improve. And
in fact that's the first thing we'll do in these assignments
is we'll come back to that question we asked in the
very beginning of the course where we ask you to rate
your identity as a designer and a developer on a scale
of one to ten. After that, you're going to have a
chance to give us some feedback. After all, you are users and we do want to
know whether we delighted or disappointed and either
way, we want to know how to do better
next time. Finally and this is the most
exciting part you will take the final project app
that you have been working on. And add
moments of delight by leveraging the power of Android.